je sois
voilà greggio
on parle français
c'est heureux de vous avoir à regretter
la dernière fois que j'ai vu c'était
dans lunettes noires pour nuit blanche
c'était il ya quinze ans et je suis
heureux de voir que vous avez toujours
là toujours la forme ça me fait plaisir
on est très heureux que la menace soit
la banane voilà pourquoi mais dans le
sens inverse
alors grace jones donc fille d'un
pasteur jamaïcain mais aux origines très
diverses origines nigérianes par votre
père écossaise par votre mère est un peu
de sang asiatique ce qu'on peut voir à
vos yeux légèrement [ __ ] et à vos
pommettes un petit peu saillantes 1
c'est vrai mais il ment mon père et les
moitiés nghien
ouvre un peu chinoise africain
c'est jamaïque voilà une sphère
l'universel graisse jaune cela vous avez
les deux soeurs et quatre frères grasset
comment
il dépasse accord
n'aura qu'à moissac
un ticket un truc puisqu'à sa
gnac chanel après barry white grèce
division
alors grace douceur et quatre frères
dont un jumeau christian et vous avez
dit en fait nos gènes se sont mélangés à
la naissance ce qui explique ma
fascination pour l'androgynie j'étais
son frère il était ma soeur il jouait la
poupée jeu jouer avec le feu toujours
c'est comme ça je suis un peu taf
[Rires]
et la musique du jeu
alors vous avez été d'abord élevée en
jamaïque par vos grands parents qui
étaient très puritain beauvau
finie la ganja ses grands parents il fut
médaille jamais coupé non c'est vrai
vous avez ni radio une télévision et
seulement dès que c'est vraiment
stimulant l'imagination et puis quelques
leçons de piano mais c'est vrai qu'au
début dans votre entreprise enfants se
graisse jaune vous avez été élevé dans
un dans un grand puritanisme et des
heureuses mal heureusement fini bien
heureusement l'angle de graisse était
évêque parce que son père était pasteur
pour une église qui s'appelle pente
coastal charts oui et l'oncle lui
étaient les etats-unis et échangés de la
région polaire mais sentant que l'été
était installé à syracuse dans l'état de
new york et un jour grace vous êtes allé
retrouver cet oncle vous l'avait rejoint
en 1964 et la syracuse j'ai pris des
cours de comédie et puis au bout d'un
moment vous êtes un petit peu ennuyé et
vous avez décidé d'aller à new york pour
rejoindre votre fameux jumeaux christian
qui lui était dit choqué à l'époque
incessants oui c'est vrai
et il est travaillé elysée matignon pour
des années oui en brésil en israël
ouais ouais gros on grandit jamie votre
wii voilà c'est donc voila vous allez
rejoindre à new york il a hélas
grace jones est remarqué par les talents
de caoutchouc par les chercheurs de
talents de lagence wilhelmina en 1974
gironde pas les années ouais
il l'a donc que vous lisez quelques
années à new york top model il lorsque
vous arrivez en france vous devenez
vraiment un des plus grands top models
européen parce que j'ai des gens non
explosées oui voilà et là donc vous
devenez grèce l'icône tellement
tellement tellement connu avec votre
look androgyne
portraiturer par andy warhol et vous
faites vos plus grandes soirées au
studio 54 ha à new york voilà ça c'est
le
clfc
avec la marque c'est l'avis de bresse
ils vous ont dit jouer passer une bonne
soirée
sans
problème et avec tous les gens qui tire
mais un vote derrière oui qui vont
entrer avec moi et tous alors j'avais
plus de rock quand j'entrais oui je
t'aime
en 1979 pour rencontrer jean paul goude
qui vous fait faire un certain nombre de
publicités très connus dont citroën vous
crachez des voitures à ce moment là la
magie on s'en souvient très bien ça se
passait très bien et ils vous
immortalise dans un livre de photos qui
s'appelle jungle fever ou vous ai tenu à
quatre pattes
voilà et à l'époque à l'époque ça fait
réagir la ministre des droits de la
femme yvette roudy vous souvenez de
saillé un scandale terrible dans cette
fosse aux hépatites et moi moi j'ai que
pas des scandales j'ai fait les
scandales 1
il va très vite et très choqué par cette
photo parce que la mairie d'hyères il ya
des graisses dans une cage à poils à
quatre pattes et marquez ne nourrissait
pas l'animal dans le sang des animaux
alors qu'elle est peu mais nous qui
étions choqués par yvette roudy sa
voix là et puis après la fin des années
80 qui est un petit peu plus difficile
vous avez des problèmes avec le fisc
vous êtes obligé de vendre votre
appartement à signer
des bons dit jamais non
j'ai donc je
vais pas vendu l'appartement
dernière
j'avais piqué tout le monde argent
là
il ya eu un problème ou sucré avec un
restaurant vous aviez ouvert à new york
c'est vrai qu'ils s'appellent à vie en
rose mais ouais y'a pas trop marcher je
crois qu'on peut le dire non ça marchait
très bien pendant un an voilà est avec
quelqu'un qui était foncé qui occupé de
ça est plutôt heureux j'étais en france
et dans tous les mauvais état dans le
restaurant de la nuit et moi j'étais
jamais là oui j'aime la grèce en hongrie
jones est tombé bien bas je n'ose pas
voilà là tous les jours c'est toujours
way d'aunis fabre était toujours son
restaurant c'est vrai contre moi quelque
chose comme moi je connais même pas fait
de cuisine ouais je fais pas et là je
dis pas non maintenant j'étais un peu
mieux j'ai fait quelque chose pour moi
pour l'heureuse à niort en avril grace
en avril 89 ya cette histoire donc de
cocaïne qu'on trouve dans votre sac
quand j'étais en jamaïque à kingston oui
et en fait c'était dans l'air
ce qu'il faut savoir et tous les bons
connais pas une histoire mais ce que je
dis pas ce que je dis à mes amis
téléspectateurs c'est qu'en fait cette
cocaïne
appartenait pas à grèce elle avait été
mise dans le sac de grace par une femme
jalouse or dit qu'on étudie l'histoire
mais c'était tellement petit de même m m
1,06 g c'est aussi je ne pouvais pas
c'est aussi vrai voilà les conséquences
du monde voilà donc je regarde leur
apprend les gestes
précis
ce qu'il faut dire à nos amis
téléspectateurs c'est que pendant que
grace cours helmand de new york à paris
à milan les restaurants les photos les
chansons doigt une vie absolument
extraordinaire que devenez le jeune
paulo l'enfant que vous avez eue avec
jean paul goude il devenait quoi a déjà
étonné les musiciens un
peintre il fait tout ce que moi ni son
père pouvait faire voilà et là tout
pour 2 nous d'où est encore plus un qui
parle bien de lui lui monsieur inverse
pour travailler au crédit
il ya une sorte de gâcher écrit deux
chansons je suis en train de faire note
nouvel album nouveau nom nouvelle je ne
sais pas quoi mais bon j'ai une chanson
qui lui
il écrit je n'ai même composition moi
j'aimais les paroles est bon nous
finalement c'est super parce qu'on
travaillait ensemble et je les pianos et
composent
ça va être superbe 700 euros
voici pour le coup des gens le demandeur
m
[Musique]
hier soir où jamel thiam est libre mais
il veut venir à côté moi je trouve que
je trouve que c'est bien c'est la polo
serviront à bien super ya jamal qui va
co animé l'émission avec moi à la vient
ici dans le pôle au goût de 23 ans
musicien bruiteur bref artistes vous
viviez à new york jusqu'à l'attentât du
11 septembre contre le world trade
center vous dites le 11 septembre a
brisé tous mes délires américain c'est à
dire
non ça n'a rien brisé c'est juste que
j'ai tout vu depuis votre fenêtre c'est
ça qui est terrible mais voilà c'est ça
en fait c'est que j'ai tout vu de ma
fenêtre
j'ai vu ça il y en a encore rien vu de
leurs fenêtres et un mac et un civil ont
vu arriver de leurs fenêtres et déjà en
avion vous résidez déjà fumé à tous 20
des avions été lancée après en fait
qu'on a eu tous peur c'est que après il
y avait le air force qui passaient et
tous les avions de chasse quoi qui
passait là on avait peur assaillent et
parfois même aujourd'hui vous avez
encore des flashes et dus à la drogue
non
c'est vrai c'est vrai que j'ai encore
des flèches de jean durand ça vous a
marqué sa griffe vous avez plus vous
avez envie de vivre à new york
aujourd'hui vous considérez que c'est
une ville fantôme non c'est l'été
pendant au moins deux semaines selon
septembre et entre ce temps-là g
vues 1
un petit coup de fil qu'on propose de
faire un spectacle et c'est là que j'ai
dit
qui vous a appelé arthur jugnot le le
fils neil d'heure l'agira même pas
répondre c'est parce que je sais pas ce
que ça tombait mais nous on a des
impératifs il ya catherine barma lequel
tout était là
alors donc il vous appelle pour un
spectacle avec gilles rang de commandeur
et la voilà arthur jugnot alors jérôme
commandeur bonsoir vous auriez vous
adhère à bout oui quel âge il a 27 ans
et sera ordinaire voilà moi je vous ai
connu vous y mettiez eros ramazzotti
je produisais l'émission à l'époque
voilà je viens que l'âge à l'époque 21
21 ans déjà et ensuite vous avez fait
maintenant si tu veux écrire tes fiches
par des rapports des vietnamiens c'est
moi qui les
rastas baignoire c'est la france 2 vous
avez fait ça voilà ensuite il ya eu
cette émission qui s'appelait l'hyper
choc a fait un carton oui et puis votre
one man show dizaine déjà mis en scène
par arthur jugnot est exactement voilà
et aujourd'hui donc vous faites un
spectacle est toujours mis en scène par
arthur jugnot qui s'appelle commandeur
et good au petit palais des glaces à
l'adresse 35 rue du faubourg du temps
pour le rallye la pousse fait nos
classes là bas le pil ces deux mecs qui
cherchent un moyen de se faire de la
thune c'est ça les deux mecs qui veulent
réussir par tous les moyens donc ils
vont démarrer dans la galère ils vont
finir animateur radio et donc on va
suivre à chaque fois leurs petits
boulots dans le monde du cirque dans le
monde à chaque fois dès qu'ils ont une
opportunité quoi voilà voilà voilà et à
leur gré si vous pouviez dire magnéto
serge ça nous arrange manette au siège
merci mr doublure de chantal goya
pour tourner gay en province bonsoir mon
bébé
c'est à tasser un peu le niveau jeudi
midi mais ba trung magie aux
tenues plaisir de vous retrouver les
enfants en tire les mêmes boucles
d'oreilles que moi mais pas au même
endroit que
d un petit cochon magnifique pour les
enfants ça me fait plaisir de voir mes
petits phoques
[Musique]
oui mais voilà
ça va la compagnie créole ne vous
dérange pas trop troisième instrument
la caisse claire
mais c'est pas possible ces trucs
non petit enfant regarde je mets ma
verges autour de polo
il n'y a absolument aucun trucage
aucun gadget sonore non plus et ben
ouais gros les commandeurs
[Applaudissements]
alors paulo vous êtes à un bruiteur
impressionnant parce que vous faites des
instruments bon ça bon nous fait un
instrument superposés je trouve
extraordinaire c'est jérôme c'est quand
y passent donc on vous fait le parrain
vous additionnez les les instruments les
uns après les autres un parent est ce
qu'on peut faire un essai là ouais vas-y
le parrain dé francis ford coppola on y
va on démarre tout de suite avec es tu
prêt par l'eau les camps politiques
[Musique]
et
bon là que vous allez aucun intérêt nous
prennent pour des cons n'est pas tort on
continue avec la sema
et
des instruments superposé
il n'y a aucun trucage on n'est pas
compétente avec sébastien aucun félin
mécanique ex on continue avec un
troisième instrument
la caisse plaît
et on continue je vais demander aux
femmes d'un certain point de rester
assise avec la grosse caisse
[Musique]
mes cheveux simplement comité
d'entreprise
[Musique]
il en
avait remis deux pas du palais en texto
mis des dj le texto barawe les textos
techno techno alzheimer serbie techno
techno ça va s'il vous plaît tacul non
c'est pour moi
non
alors paulo et entendu mes bras
quel est donc y aller oui quel est le
bruit paulo que vous préférez la capsule
j'aime bien ouais j'aime bien ouvrir les
canettes fait voir
c'est tout con le bruit qui vous fait
peur on va attendre le
salon de kfar sava compris apparemment
le prix qui vous fait penser à votre
mère bruit double pour samedi
la police le voyez qui vous rend fou
c'est quoi bruits qui me rend fou c'est
le silence
de dieu
oui je suis le mieux mais je pas on fait
plein mes amis l'avaient fait en musique
de madonna ou sinon ouais c'est comme en
musique de madonna procès
c'est par une foire
ben ça se passe bien entre vous deux ça
va avec ben ouais tu peux faire lâcher
pu survivre et je te survivre non mais
qui sait faire une jivaro qui sait faire
nougaro la
twa plazy
armstrong je ne suis pas noir je suis
blanc de peau
qu'on l'écrive blanc sur noir ou bien
noir sur blanc on chante pour toi louis
howie chante chante chante ça tient
chaud j'ai froid oh moi qui suis blanc
de pro à
quand le jazz
est quand le jazz et la java sans la
java 120 il vient d'une journée les
biens de l'eau dans le gaz entre le jazz
et la java
si tu nous regardes
bien alors ça se passe très bien entre
entre vous et votre maman paulo c'est
pas super mais on va quand même faire
des interviews maman j'ai un truc à te
dire
[Musique]
voilà vous allez poser des questions à
votre maman paul goude et graisse jaune
va se faire un plaisir d'y répondre
un message de claude nougaro pour nous
dire qu'ils voient un coup un petit
cadeau et nous embrasse
vas-y paulo message des questions à ta
maman tu écoutes maman
et si et si je t'annonce et qu'en fait
je suis homo et je sors avec commandeur
tu prendrais comme un tout le portrait
de son père
[Rires]
non je dis bon j'étais prête pour ça
depuis tennessee ça arrive ça arrive
si tu es content
oui parce qu'on a on a désormais dans
notre famille
jusqu'à 3,6 film
et je suis très content c'est sûr on dit
m
je crois que maintenant on peut dire ils
sont ensemble deuxième question pour le
haut pour quelques titres deuxième
question attention grace
et si je t'annonce et que j'étais
malheureux quand j'étais jeune je le
prendrais comment
âgées dit oui excusez moi c'est
je peux faire quelque chose maintenant
pour changer tout ça c'était content
maintenant on est tous un peu malheureux
parfois c'est vrai la vie c'est pas
comme ça la vie c'est bon ça roule ça
roulait quand il faut qu'un pas c'est
tout
du tout je parlais du tout voilà
question suivante paulo
et si je t'annonce et que je me drogue
tu prendrais comment j'ai dit
laissez-moi essayé d'abord
va pas changer en fait non à l'époque
les pillages avec les païens ya une
ambiance un
poster pour cette question attention à
ma
maman et si je t'annonce et que j'en ai
marre d'avoir des parents célèbres tu te
prends mais quand tu prendrais comment
mais ça si tu veux dit ça tue mais
jamais je n'ai jamais tu médias choses
comme ça si tu dis ça je dis parce que
non je vais pas je dis c'est peut-être
les gens autour de toi qui aimes et ça
dans ta tête parce que ça vient pas de
moi nous ton père voilà monsieur qui se
font claquer il faut que la cré les
autres ok
ok
et si je t'annonce est que je soutiens
de georges bush tu prendrais comment si
tu soutiens ouais si je te disais que je
soutenais george bush
fait roger dallas et ce projet de george
bush
dire
mais quand même c'est quand même cet
avis finalement des
tulipes et
cachée bien cachés
continue poil à la sacem et si je
t'annonce et que j'ai quitté une fille
que j'ai mise enceinte tu prendrais
comment
ça vraiment ses ventes ont décision je
la respecte et passionnant jeu s'était
acquitté de
nuke non non je dis seulement
cccl veut avoir l'enfant qui est quand
même du ponant responsabilités pour
l'enfant etc non non non non pas papa
c'est sympa mais vite fait je
pense de l'enfant quand j'ai 11 ans père
de l'enfant voilà un
bon et si je talent c'est que je faire
un vrai métier comme informaticien ou
expert comptable tu prendrais comment tu
fais le meilleur le meilleur dans le
métier que tu choisis
ces mamans
ce
[Musique]
que moi dit paulo continuer ou pas que
ta mère alors soit on perd
un peu plus bronzé
cette embellie
non mais ma maman mais je tombe par
terre ouais j'ai bien de devoir il ment
mais une bombe c'est plus à
quand une épaule au bon g t au et 6 août
annoncé que je préfère être avec papa tu
prendrais comme moi et je suis ans en
rajoute annonce jeudi s'est vu plein
familiale
et si je t'annonce est que je veux me
convertir à l'islam
moi je crois dans toutes les révisions
moi je moi je suis pas
comme si comme on dis je
non je suis spirituel si c'est quelque
chose qui portent quelque chose pour qu
elles positives dans toutes les
religions moi je suis d'accord juste une
cultivant et si je talent c'est que papa
m'a fait fumer mon premier pétard tu
prendrais comment donnez moi un peu
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu